[Music]  deputy chairman fred hampton of the  illinois black panther party  [Applause]  repeat after me  [Applause]  you're looking at 18 months  for the stolen car five years for  impersonating a federal officer  or you can go home  the black panthers are forming a rainbow  coalition  of oppressed brothers and sisters of  every color their aim  is to show hatred and inspire terror i  will learn  all that i care these ain't no  terrorists  you can murder a liberator you can't  murder liberation  you can learn a revolutionary but you  can't murder revolution  i need to murder a freedom fighter but  you can't learn  [Applause]  me  [Music]  [Music]  you